we really need to give each woman her
own choice
to to have and navigate her life
[Music]
karen thank you so much for joining me
on 20 minute leaders how are you
great thank you for having me you know
just a few months ago we
we met for coffee back in israel who
would have imagined that here we are
in the uh middle of may trying to figure
out how the world is going to look like
next month
right right i couldn't imagine
couldn't imagine now karen you a you
have a particularly interesting story
and i'm very excited to talk
about one of the programs that you
founded called
a woman to woman a leadership excellence
program
that helps women both from the tech
units but also from all across the
industry
and really extraordinary women all over
israel to
to take great strides towards becoming
better leaders
and having prominent positions in the
industry
can you tell me a little bit about where
you come from and how this idea of woman
to women actually came about
sure so i am a 8200 graduate
and and so in the unit we have 50
female soldiers which is something that
usually
uh surprises people who didn't serve in
the unit
because when you hear about successful
entrepreneurs or people who got to
leadership positions in israel you
usually hear about men
um so so they are 50 female
and what we we found out i'm one of the
co-founders i
um with me uh two other founders
um and what we found out is that there
are two factors
that actually uh um they're
putting uh women uh in a in different
stage
right so first is that women usually uh
take a step back
uh even before they think about their
career and having a family
uh so even when they choose what to
study
or where to go or what to do in their
life
and the second thing is that we have
there is a lack of women that could be
role models
in israel so women that got to
high-level positions
and are willing to uh to pass it forward
so that's how uh we found we founded
woman
woman with the idea of creating the next
generation of female leaders in israel
women so so you know
let's dive a little bit deeper so talk
to me a little bit about what does it
take to
to create a leadership program and also
what skills do you think are missing
to help bridge that gap skills that
um that you're trying to promote through
woman to woman
so uh i think that women uh and again
generally
um i think they're they're at least good
as men
but
thank you so uh so i think that
um there are things um that
again generally women are not that good
at
um and it goes to soft skills
that relates to negotiation or
presentation
or even presenting themselves in a way
like
talking about uh uh all of the
successful things
that they've done and their attributes
so so it's it's
difficult for women to talk about that
um and we feel
that this is something that we need to
work on with them
uh so that's one thing and also
understanding
that they could do both like having a
successful career and
family which is something that if you
look about
like if you look at at the last
generation you know our parents
so usually uh uh women
took a different role in the house right
um so so right now we want to change
that
and that's that's actually uh the first
time the first generation
that we really want to have equal
opportunities
and that's something that is not really
happening even in 2020.
yeah you know i mean right now i mean
it's very evident you have women like
sheryl sandberg and ronald sagev and
adisa fertiani
that are really you know pioneers and
and they're doing just extraordinary
things
but you also have these crazy stories of
marissa mayer
you know back then the ceo of yahoo who
gives birth and
i think the myth was of the three days
three days she was in the office i mean
wow and and you know it's so i'm sure
you have to find some balance right
i can't imagine that that it can be
assumed that either the woman or the men
will come to the office three days after
after giving birth
but what can you do to sort of level the
gap
between the maternity leave of the woman
and the that of the father
that's great a great point um so so
first
i believe that every every woman has
uh her own choice right and if if
someone like if she thinks that she can
come back to the office after a day or
two days or three
days it's fine because she needs to to
feel good with herself
um and you know women experience uh
you know this maternity leave in
different ways which
which is okay and i think that part of
uh um
you know asking for for equality
um and and equal opportunities is also
understanding
that women are also different among
themselves
uh according to you know what they
believe and what they see and
the way they feel about family and we
really need to accept that
we really need to give uh each woman her
own choice
to to have and navigate her life
uh you know across these two major
things with her career and
her own personal life so that's first
second
i agree that we have amazing uh women
that are pioneers
um and also in our program we have rona
berry
and and we have fiona del mon and really
amazing women
um and they're really putting their time
in order to help
uh younger women which is amazing in my
opinion
and they also talk about their
difficulties you know
which which there are a lot of them uh
in in also in their balance uh you know
work and family and what they've done in
order to balance that
completely and you also see other
companies
in the industry who are taking the
reverse approach and they're saying
why is it that women only are expected
to
to spend time with the family men the
fathers should be there just as much as
just as long as the women and i believe
that both google and facebook they took
their step
in in in equalizing the the leave the
vacation the paid vacation leave after
giving birth
so talk to me a little bit about woman
to woman how does that program actually
run
because these women are already you know
they're they're excellent candidates for
continuing in leadership positions
they're very busy
is it structured like an emba sort of or
is it
is it a meetup based how does it work so
so the problem is is about six months
during this six months we have
one-on-one mentoring
like one-on-one mentorship uh so we have
these mentors amazing mentors on one
side and the younger
uh the younger women on the other side
right and they are meeting each other
through this
sixth month and uh besides that we have
a lot of
meetups uh for the mentors and the
mentees
so uh with the mentees were working as i
said about their soft skills and like
um and even creating their their path
right
so where do you want to go when it where
when they want to get these kind of
positions
why they want to achieve uh uh you know
family wise
um and how do you really navigate their
career
and working with them on that and then
on the mentor side
we also work on creating a very
very very influential uh um group
of women in high leadership positions
that are working in order to promote
women um in their organizations right
and this mentorship it's actually
what's unique about it is that you're
forming these really incredible
relationships
with some of the most prominent women in
the israeli ecosystem
and it's not just you know a one-off hey
give me an hour coffee and let me share
some of my dilemmas
you're actually building these intense
relationships where
the goal is for them to help their
mentees
progress to the c-level and executive
positions is that right
right right what we understood is that
even in 2020
um even though we have very very
talented women around the age of 30
let's say when you look at this point
so even so they're so talented and they
want to get to the sea levels
uh positions not all of them are going
together
and not because they're not good enough
it's just because um because it's life
right because
they will have much more um it could be
much more difficult for them so what we
do is just
we take them hand by hand and we just
make sure
that they're reaching those positions
okay so so you know how many how many
um cycles has this program gone for and
how many women have gone through this
program
so we've already had uh four cycles
and one than 160 uh mentees
wonderful 160 mentees that's a lot of
data
i'm a data guy i i love looking at data
and and
you know extrapolating to to some of the
bigger picture
questions and and what have you learned
over these 160 mentees
all extraordinary women to begin with
i'm sure some of them went on to
already become sea level executives some
of them are underway
some of them perhaps have realized that
they don't actually want to or maybe
that it's more
that they're not fit for that i'm sure
that's a possibility too
what have what earned secrets have you
learned as
the founder of this looking at these 160
women
so i think that i've learned
that that how important it is to have a
community
that supports you so some of them are
coming from different backgrounds
yeah and different ethnic authenticity
is right so
so some of them are heretic and some of
them are not and some of them
you know different uh uh communities in
israel
you have parading women in the program
yeah really yeah we do
we do okay which is amazing yeah and you
know and
and and arm and none are like different
different communities
um and not all of them
are coming from a background
that really uh supports them
and and you know and pushes them um
so i feel that having this community
of i'm talking about the mentees
themselves yeah
without the mentors so having this
community
of women that help each other and open
doors for each other this is this is
something amazing i've heard
one of our of our illuminati so she told
me like she called
i gave her a number uh of some of
one of our alumni from from the first
psycho um
and i didn't tell her that i'm giving
her number uh so she called
and like the daughter uh person on the
line so she was like
are you one to woman luna okay i will
help you i will do whatever you need i
will
like i will help you in whatever i can
um
so they're really helping each other and
and i think that's
that's a gift like oh that that sounds
incredible yeah
i think i think about this question a
lot as the
chicken and the egg sort of where you
have uh
you expect on one hand i'm looking now
in the cyber space
in 8200 where you know even though the
unit as a whole
has an equal ratio of of male to females
in the cyber space i think it's more
like nine to one
male to female which is also there a lot
there are a lot of programs trying to
help
make that transition more to equality
but what i was thinking about at night
and i had i had
a third of my team were were females so
we actually
broke the law that for the rest of it
which i was very proud of
and i kept thinking that like wow this
like i can imagine the struggle
of even when you get a fantastic woman
engineer
or analyst or whatever to come in she
has to go and now sit in a room
with seven eight other guys with very
few representation of of other women
that's very intimidating and i'm
thinking back to high school
where you have classrooms cs classrooms
filled with
with men that's intimidating to go and
be the odd one out and i'm almost
wondering
how do we break the cycle where we stop
this intimidation
and we just level the playing field very
good question
um so i think that like what we do
is we work with companies as well uh so
exactly as i said
uh being the only woman at the room is
very difficult
it's like it's very hard so we're
working with companies
in order to to have them change
uh the way that they're thinking about
even even recruiting women like we're
talking to
managers that are men about like the
differences
and how they are recording and how they
are performing
the interviews and then like even the
seating
um and what happens when a woman is
pregnant
uh um so so sometimes she needs you know
to have
a parking space you know sometimes and
sometimes
uh there are special or not special like
different things
uh that a woman needs or or or that
would help her
achieve uh achieve her potential right
so so we're really like working with
companies in order to help them create
an environment that enables women to get
uh to the high level positions wonderful
karen
we have just about five minutes left and
i'd love to use this time to learn a
little bit
more about you so tell me you know where
do you come from you did 8200 you
founded
this incredible organization that is now
continuing to do great things
but you're also working full-time in the
industry
so tell me a little bit about what
interests you and what excites you
so um i'm really excited about
uh about changing things that i
don't really agree with okay so
it also relates to to women uh
and to the women equality and to other
uh you know communities in israel that
are currently
not having the same representation
as they should have um in the industry
so that's
something that really excites me um and
i really
uh so i'm working in the finance
industry uh
in the cyber security industry like in
finance position and i really love that
i really like that um you know the
combination of
uh thinking about uh um the the next uh
next product and how you go to the
market and then how you get
money out of that um so i really like
that
um i think that's it so so
so tell me a little bit about what
you're how do you balance these things
so you're running this
this organization that takes a lot of
time to work on it's a lot of
relationship building a lot of meetings
and an effort i know from organizing uh
hackathon events which are you know
one-time events
that facilitate these relationships that
takes a lot of effort at the same time
you're working
full time at the other at a company and
you're also probably working on other
stuff that you're excited about how do
you balance everything
um so i i think that i found a way
um that also like when i when when i'm
coming
uh to project like i really know to
really understand uh what it takes like
how many hours i'm going to spend on
that um i don't have weekends
uh i have a wonderful husbands and
amazing friends and family
uh they are very supportive uh
and that's something that really helps
and i also
think that once you do something that
you really love
and you care about um and
so so like your life like everything
sorts
sorting in a better way like everything
is okay
so if i ask you how many hours how many
hours a week
do you work because you know full-time
job takes 40 hours but you're actually
saying that i
i don't work for 40 hours technically i
work for much more but i don't consider
that as work
right right correct so so usually i
do i don't know 30 hours of volunteering
a week and 30 hours of volunteering
yeah and about 50 hours 30 hours
like i don't sleep much no no but like
where do you volunteer like what what is
what is your volunteer work
so woman to women takes a lot of time
right we're we're now 12
women at team which is amazing but it
still takes a lot of time
is everybody down here we have someone
that is uh is helping us and get
uh full-time uh full-time job but okay
all the others are volunteering um and
uh
and yeah i do love a lot of stuff that i
really believe in
that's that's wonderful how do you how
do you from the sidelines make sure that
the quality remains
as when you just started out because you
know it's it's a it's a very emotional
personal project
and i'm sure that you know some
sometimes there are decisions being made
that you're not entirely happy with or
that you don't feel are the best
how do you balance now that you're also
working on other stuff
um very good question when i'll know the
answer i'll get back to you
wonderful so it's
it's hard i like i try to i try to do
compromises
in in in um where i feel that i can do
them
um and and keep the quality in the
highest level
uh in places where i feel that we can't
compromise on
uh so just balancing uh between our
activities
and things that we're doing um in order
to you know also to maintain
the brand and and and amazing women that
are
coming to our program okay that's
wonderful karen we're almost that done
but
but i'd love to ask my favorite question
the three words that
best describe yourself or you know three
words that
one of the 160 women who went through
this wonderful program
would describe you as um
so i think the three
words describe um the program
and what we're trying uh to do is
like create uh
change and impact i love it karen
thank you very very much
and i'm look i look forward to our next
coffee back in israel
whenever that will be possible wonderful
thank you take care